[Musique]
j'ai bien dit que là ça ne va pas
l'appétit
non non comment voulez vous que ça y est
je viens de lire là on va encore ajouté
un autre produit chimique peut-être au
pam le monastère et pourquoi faire pour
l'empêcher de durcir comme si ça ne
suffisait pas le vin avec des colorants
les pommes couverte d'insecticides
la viande provenant d'animaux engraisser
avec des antibiotiques la salade avec
des engrais chimiques et ça n'est plus
possible
oui la liste des produits chimiques
qu'on ajoute à l'alimentation augmentent
tous les jours
est-ce qu'il faut vraiment croire tout
ce qu'on dit au sujet du danger de ces
produits chimiques
vous savez le sujet suffisamment grave
parce que tout notre avenir non pas
seulement le nôtre mais celui des
enfants
l'alimentation de l'an 2000 est tout de
même suffisamment importante pour
l'avenir de l'espèce pour que nous ne
fassions une enquête
il faut il faut que nous allions voir
tous les spécialistes tous ceux qui
s'occupent de toxicologie d'alimentation
où nous éclairer sur ce sujet
oui c'est un problème important que
celui des produits chimiques qui de plus
en plus souvent sont ajoutés à notre
alimentation
tout le monde en parle mais comme c'est
difficile d'y voir clair pour certains
notre nourriture quotidienne est à ce
point trafic et que nous nous
empoisonnent ont lentement tous les
jours les industriels de l'alimentation
protestent et affirme qu'il n'en est
rien et que leurs produits sont sans
danger
qui faut-il croire autrefois lorsque
nous achetions un bifteck des légumes ou
des fruits
nous avions à nous préoccuper que de
leurs étapes fraîcheur de leur apparence
de qualité ou leur valeur nutritive
aujourd'hui même aux marchands des
quatre saisons nous sommes tentés de
demander si ces pommes ne sont pas
saupoudrer d'insecticides 6 et légumes
ne contiennent pas de conservateurs
chimiques nous méfions même d'aliments
aussi essentiel est aussi simple que la
viande les oeufs le pain au levain sont
ils vraiment devenu dangereux à
consommer parce qu'ils contiennent trop
de produits chimiques toxiques
la protection contre les risques
provenant de l'industrialisation des
aliments est elle efficace
nous allons essayer de répondre à ces
questions
premier point de notre enquête
existe-t-il des produits chimiques dans
notre nourriture oui c'est vrai et il ne
pourrait en être autrement
les hommes sont de plus en plus nombreux
à nos besoins alimentaires augmentent en
même temps que notre niveau de vie
la production de nourriture est
aujourd'hui une industrie dont les
impératifs sont de fournir sans cesse
davantage d'aliments et au prix de
revient le cuba c'est cette évolution
qui commandent l'addition de produits
chimiques à tous les stades de la chaîne
alimentaire
nous ne pouvons plus revenir en arrière
l'humanité montrait rapidement de faim
si nous n'avions plus d'engrais
chimiques qui augmente le rendement plus
d'insecticides chimiques pour préserver
les récoltes plus de conservateurs
chimiques pour stocker les légumes
né dans les corps nus des chimistes les
produits de synthèse utiles à
l'agriculture aux industries
d'alimentation se chiffre aujourd'hui
par milliers ils sont fabriqués par
tonne en usine et chaque jour il en
apparaît de nouveau et le mouvement
continuera certaines sont ils tous
réellement indispensable
peut-on prouver que ce que l'on utilise
actuellement ne sont pas nocifs
ce sont les deux grandes questions que
chacun se pose
[Musique]
prenons les engrais chimique par exemple
il est certain qu'il y joue un rôle
déterminant leur utilisation a permis en
un demi siècle
de multiplier par deux le rendement des
céréales les engrais d'ailleurs ne font
qu'apporter au sol sous une forme
facilement assimilable des éléments
indispensables à la croissance des
végétaux la zot tout la potasse par
exemple que la terre ne possède plus
parce que les précédentes récolte
l'autre puiser
a priori les engrais ne pose guère de
problème ce n'est pas le cas des
insecticides meurtrier pour les insectes
ils sont également dangereux pour
l'homme ils sont à l'origine de nombreux
cas d'intoxication
en théorie il ne devrait jamais
subsistent et d'insecticides dans les
aliments que nous consommons
ce n'est pas toujours le cas ma faute
souvent il en reste seulement des traces
trop faible pour nous empoisonner
rapidement mais comment savoir si à la
longue ces traces ne favoriseront pas un
trouble plus grave le cancer par exemple
c'est cela le double problème des
additifs chimiques dans l'alimentation
d'un côté le nombre des produits de
synthèse utilisable et tels que des
erreurs involontaires ou des fraudes
peuvent se produire et provoquer des
intoxications immédiate d'un autre côté
les spécialistes même sont inquiets car
ils ne sont pas toujours certain que
même les produits légalement autorisés
soient réellement inoffensif à long
terme
ils sont souvent désarmés pour contrôler
les résidus susceptibles de polluer à
faible dose nos aliments
[Musique]
bon
le danger existe c'est donc certain et
c'est probablement pour cela que l'on
assiste actuellement à la multiplication
de ces magasins spécialisés où sont
vendus des produits garantis naturel
cette garantie est elle réelle ce n'est
pas évident nous le verrons mais
écoutons quelques réflexions entendues
dans ses magasins elles traduisent bien
la méfiance vis-à-vis de l'aliment
chimique d ici les produits naturels
c'est à dire c'est à dire sans colorant
sans produits chimiques sans
conservateur oui régulièrement du pain
des gâteaux
j'ai toujours dû bière ou le différentes
sucreries et pourquoi vous les achetez
bien parce que c'est très bon c'est très
naturel oui je pense que c'est très bon
pour la santé
et vous vous emportez bien très bien
très très bien bien sûr pour moi il n'y
a pas d'autre solution pour vivre en
bonne santé il faut bien ce nom j'achète
des oeufs lait yaourt
du beurre du fromage de l'hydromel mon
mari aime beaucoup et vous avez
l'impression que l'alimentation
habituelle des gens maintenant et elle
est infâme
il est infâme et j'en fasse c'est
ignoble rien que quand vous voyez les
pommes de terre qu'on ose vous vendre
c'est insensé qu'on s'empoisonne à
longueur de journée brooks est ça vous
avez l'air d'être assez convaincu est-ce
que vous en parler autour de moi oui je
suis tout à fait convaincu
oui certainement j'en parle autour de
noir les gens sont maintenant se
laissent de plus en plus convaincant
parce qu'ils sont dégoûtés de ce qu'ils
mangent et qu'il se rende calque fallait
essayer de vivre le plus sainement
possible économiquement il est
impossible de venir aux aliments dits
naturels
c'est au contraire vers une
industrialisation encore plus poussé que
va notre alimentation au centre de
recherche agronomique de jouy en josas
où nous commençons notre enquête on
s'efforce de trouver des procédés
nouveaux pour engraisser plus vite les
animaux de boucherie pour que les vaches
fournissent davantage de lait pour que
les poulets soient consommables en moins
de temps en apparence cela ne semble pas
dangereux il on mélange des
antibiotiques qu'est la nourriture des
animaux pour lutter contre les maladies
ce qui augmente de 30 % la croissance de
ces animaux si ces antibiotiques ne sont
pas détruites par la cuisson disent les
médecins
nous les manchots et cela devient
dangereux
[Musique]
pour faire grossir plus vite les poulets
on a mélangé des hormones à leur
alimentation
le résultat fut spectaculaire mais
certains consommateurs en ont subi les
conséquences
leur équilibre hormonal troublé ils ont
failli changer de sexe cette adjonction
d'hormones est interdite en france
depuis 1959 les adresses autorisé dans
d'autres pays il faudrait ajouter encore
à cette liste les antiparasitaires les
antimicrobiens les substances chimiques
contre l'oxydation des graisses
en france l'utilisation de tels produits
il est autorisé par une commission
interministérielle qui après des essais
dans un centre officiels comme celui de
jouy en josas essai destiné à prouver
que leur ingestion par les consommateurs
n'est pas dangereuse mais il faut bien
dire que tous les hygiénistes sont pas
d'accord sur l'absence de risque surtout
à long terme pour certains de ses
produits
nous avons continué notre enquête par le
pain il est l'objet de discussions
passionnées et certains vont jusqu'à
affirmer que le pain d'aujourd'hui et
chimiques et qu'il faudrait revenir au
pain complet naturel d'autrefois
que faut-il en penser le grain qui
arrivent par péniche de 250 tonnes vers
un grand moulin parisien n'a pas échappé
aux obligations d'une production massive
et économique
le blé a poussé sur des engrais pour
protéger le grain contre les insectes
contre les moisissures
on a utilisé plusieurs produits
chimiques en reste-t-il dans la farine
oui la législation française admet qu'on
puisse s'en retrouver et doses faibles
rien d'autre n'est ajouté au moulin
pendant les opérations mécanisées
presque automatique de broyage de
tamisage jusqu'à la mise en sac après
pourtant chez le boulanger la farine
reçoit encore des additifs de l'acide
ascorbique par exemple pas nocif puisque
c'est de la vitamine c de la levure
aussi chimiques mais non dangereuses
on en met pourtant trop bien souvent
quelquefois aussi mais clandestinement
car cela n'est pas autorisé des brommat
pour blanchir la pape commencera le pain
de l'an 2000 pas très différent de celui
d'aujourd'hui
sinon que sa fabrication sera plus
industrielles encore sur le modèle peut
être de cette boulangerie de
l'assistance publique où toutes les
opérations sont mécanisés du pétrissage
de la pâte au façonnage des baguettes et
à leur cuisson
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la seule opération manuelle et le coup
de couteau qui va donner son relief à la
baguette parisienne
on fabrique ainsi chaque nuit 10000
points pour les malades des hôpitaux
mais cette fabrication industrielle
posent les problèmes lorsqu'on accélère
trop la production de la pâte
le pain est moins bon ton il est fait
que celui que nous mangeons aujourd'hui
ne reste fait que vos peu de temps
faudrait-il rajouter du son à la farine
pour qu'ils soient moins blanc c'est un
autre sujet de controverse
laissons-leur aux jeunes élèves de
l'école de boulangerie de paris qui
seront les maîtres boulangers de l'an
2000 sous la direction de monsieur
guinée ils apprennent leur métier
[Musique]
fournée
regardez le fin vous faites bien de son
époque
alors voila mais ce qu'est ce qui a
coupé saupin c'est vous alors vous
pouvez constater que votre premier coup
de lame et beaucoup de recours par
rapport au dernier
quant à celui là voyez ce paraît moins
développés parce que fulham n'est pas
chiffré par contre je pense que les
normes à louhans cuis qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
la cuisson est bonne
c'est vu
un progrès est évident dans cette
industrialisation de la boulangerie
l'utilisation de plus en plus courante
est de toute façon désormais obligatoire
des fours à un chauffage indirects il
évite de mélanger hop indé suis native
ainsi modernisé le four traditionnel
sera encore longtemps utilisé passons
maintenant aux vins laisse vraiment un
vin de produits chimiques aussi variés
que nocifs comme on le dit souvent
nous avons continué notre enquête a
bercy c'est un grand négociant l'un de
ceux que la rumeur publique accusent de
fabriquer des vins trafic et chimiques
mauvais pour la santé
[Musique]
ici les vins sont mélangées entre dans
de grandes cuves à l'aide de vannes
commandés à distance par une sorte de
machine électronique
c'est ce qu'on appelle le coupage deux
opérations chimiques seulement sont
faites ici
la première est le collage c'est-à-dire
l'adjonction vendent un produit
gélatineux qui entraîne les impuretés au
fond de la cuve
la seconde est l'addition d'anhydride
sulfureux pour empêcher les
fermentations secondaire surtout utilisé
pour les vins blanc sucré nous y
reviendrons
[Musique]
directeur technique de ce négociant en
vin nous avons posé franchement la
question est il vrai que votre vin soit
trafic et qui les commandent y fabriquer
non je ne passerai pas votre point de
vue il n'y a plus heureusement de gens
qui prétendent que le vin est un produit
fabriqué d'antan alors que le public
était mal informé
cette légende pouvaient circuler
aujourd'hui les gens sont trop au
courant de ce qui se passe dans nos
entreprises pour savoir que le vin n'est
pas fabriqué du reste quels avantages y
aurait-il fabriquer du vin un avantage
financier absolument auquel et nous en
parlions tout à l'heure les lois sont
telles que même un négociant voudrait-il
s'amuser pour des raisons que tu lui
seraient propres à fabriquer du vin très
rapidement la fraude serait déceler car
nous sommes extrêmement contrôlée c'est
un bien du reste et nous souhaitons
vivement
mais tous ces contrôles empêche
formellement que l'on puisse fabriquer
du vin ce qu'il irait du reste aucun
sens bon ce n'est pourtant pas un secret
le vin contient effectivement des
produits finis s'ils ne sont pas versées
dans le vin à bercy l'opération serait
peut-être avant pour le savoir nous
sommes allés au pays du vin pouvait l'un
des experts en la matière le professeur
jaune dans son laboratoire de la faculté
de pharmacie de montpellier
c'est là qu'ont été mises au point les
méthodes d'analysé qui permettent de
reconnaître les produits chimiques qui
se trouve dans le vin c'est ainsi qu'on
dépiste les fraudes elles sont nombreux
près de dix mille sacs à main en fait la
législation française autorise quatre
fonctions au vin d'une trentaine de
produits divers
tous ne sont pas placés à la fois il
faut le dire
beaucoup ne semble pas dangereux mais
enfin c'est tout de même beaucoup
de toute façon il paraît que nous
n'avons pas le choix
sans additifs chimiques le vin ne serait
pas du vin mais écoutons le professeur
jaune
on pourrait y arriver mais il ya de
l'autre iran risque est le plus souvent
on obtiendrait non pas un bord d'un
memory vinaigre en effet si on essaie
entièrement faire la nature le sucre
dans son mental col d'une façon plus ou
moins complète mais les agents de
l'acidification sont là tous prêts à
s'emparer de cet alcool pour transformer
en acide acétique et jean ne surveillez
pas le travail de la nature si on
voulait guider pas le rendement de des
caves serait très mauvais et sont
extrêmement aléatoires donc il est
absolument nécessaire de mettre des
produits chimiques pour obtenir un vin
de qualité
il est généralement nécessaire d'en
mettre une petite quantité est
évidemment si une vingtaine de produits
ont dit 600 de bagnères pour l'aimer
tous les vins dans chaque poule à car le
traitement que l'on fait subir un vin
consiste qu'à l'addition de deux ou
trois produits chimiques inoffensif dont
je pourrais vous donner non pas la liste
mais un aperçu ces produits sont par
exemple d'école qui sont la gélatine qui
sont de l'avis mines qui sont du sang
frais la quasi nous tous produits qui
sont par ailleurs des produits
alimentaires qui au contact des vins se
coagulent 1 permettant la clarification
de ce liquide
on emploie également des arches il que
le chaos la bentonite qui sont s'ils
sont de bonne qualité
reste que dans le mât pour filtrer le
vin on emploie des des cartons et
cellulose des cartons amiante ou des
toiles que l'on quelque sorte que van
hulle en alluvions n'avait qu'une terre
insoluble qui est la date au 8 août
ardèche histoire qui lorsqu'il a une
bonne qualité de réception une marianne
enlevé on peut l'autocar dans certains
cas ajouter des produits qui modifie
quelque peu la composition du vin
lorsque le vin n'est pas celle ci dont
on est autorisé à ajouter un peu d'acide
tartrique produits qui provient du vin
par conséquent qui ne saurait être
étranger à ce liquide
on peut ajouter un peu d'acide citrique
quantité limitée au contraire des années
où le vin est trop acide l'année où
l'été n'est pas assez chaud le ministre
de l'agriculture peut autoriser
l'addition de d insignifiants qui est
généralement soit ne tentera pas de
potassium ou sol carbone à dos
chaussures sens totalement inoffensive
il n'ya qu'eux
quelques produits qui sont un peu comme
un virage un peu suspecte qui entourent
ou plus avec les élections qui ont été
de l' objet de discussions et qui sont
encore l'objet de discussions au point
de vue de leur innocuité total il n'y a
guère que deux produits sur lesquels on
puisse encore discuté la mairie
sulfureux est un produit qui utilisaient
de tout temps les romains je connaissais
déjà on connaissait les remarquables
propriétés et les sauts et bien c'est
d'abord un rôle d' sélection des levures
que la vinification lui permet d'avoir
de plus des vinifications plus régulière
il permet d'autre part de conserver le
vin et en luttant en arrêtant le
développement des fermes en maladie les
deux maladies principales sont la tombe
et la piqûre qu'il transforme le
vinaigre
c'est donc un produit indispensable
essais contre un pour dispensable on n'a
pas constaté de nos activités nocives
sur les rats aux doses légales
donc il est impossible que les
consommateurs de vins soit intoxiqué
pendant les crises futures a sûrement
pas rares dans les galets ou visuel
encore moins bon et l'autre produit
nôtre où les îles féroe chaîne sûrs il
fusionne le potassium a été introduit en
hydrologie parma stringer un expert ni
légalement il ya une quarantaine
d'années est ce qui vous est arrivé de
trouver dans du
les noces de ferrocyanure qui risque
d'être dangereuse pour ceux qui restent
vains nous avons fait des expériences en
mettant une dose trop forte de
ferrocyanure nous avons également eu
quelques vins expertise mais nous
n'avons jamais trouvé dans ce vin une
quantité de fer d'acide citrique
susceptibles de toxiques en effet dans
les caddies plus défavorable il faut des
consommateurs consomment dans une heure
250 litres de vin ce qui est
rigoureusement impossible pour absorber
en même temps une dose toxique ce que
dit le professeur jaune mais il faut le
croire
vous il faut avouer que cela n'est pas
satisfaisant il paraît que les hommes de
science s'efforce de trouver des
procédés nouveaux de traitement des vins
qui permettront de réduire le nombre des
additifs chimiques
le vin de l'an 2000 seraient donc moins
chimique que celui d'aujourd'hui
acceptons-en l'auguré car dans bien
d'autres domaines de l'alimentation
la tendance est bien plutôt à
l'augmentation du nombre des produits
chimiques
l'arrivée des récipients en matière
plastique par exemple suscite déjà des
inquiétudes
on vend bouteilles plastiques de l'huile
ou du vin est on certain que le recul
est suffisant pour décider que les
traces de plastique qui passe
nécessairement dans l'huile dans le vin
ne sont pas nocives à la longue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avant de lancer ses emballages en
plastique sur le marché les industriels
on demandait aux chimistes et
biologistes d'effectuer des recherches
elles ont été menées par exemple au
laboratoire de l'institut d'hygiène
alimentaire sous la responsabilité de
son directeur monsieur brun on a choisi
à la suite de ces travaux des plastiques
stable sans toxicité mais il a fallu
aussi comme l'expliquent monsieur brun
se préoccuper des produits utilisés pour
fabriquer les plastiques les adjuvants
mais le problème des adjuvants
d'abord les stabilisants et c'est
surtout sur ce problème là où nous
sommes orientés
car ce sont des substances chimiques qui
même à très faibles doses avait la peau
pouvait avoir la pause pouvait entraîner
une certaine toxicité s'il passait dans
l'aliment nous avons donc étudié un
certain nombre de stabilisants et parmi
eux l'ont fait d'un choix et nous avons
gardé celui qui présentait aucun risque
après des études de plusieurs mois être
plusieurs années sur l'animal non
seulement nous avons étudié la réaction
d' animal à des doses à des à
l'administration de petites quantités
répéter quotidiennement
mais parallèlement nous avons regardé
comment s'est produit ce métaboliser
pour voir s'il ne risquait pas de
perturber un carrefour quelconque des
réactions chimiques de l'organisme ces
réactions les déviants et pouvant
directement ou indirectement entraîné un
accident et les accidents il faut bien
lire que nous redoutons le plus ce sont
des accidents insidieux qu'ils peuvent
se révéler que plusieurs mois après la
jonction et l'ingestion donc comme vous
pensez sont excellentes des accidents
cancérogénèse qui nous préoccupe le plus
[Musique]
ici encore il faut bien le dire il
subsiste une incertitude et bien sûr les
fabricants son tour de toutes les
précautions on multiplie les analyses et
les expériences sur les animaux les
plastiques ne sont certainement pas
toxique mais si leur usage se généralise
si nous absorbons dans l'avenir
davantage de ces traces de substances
nocives
il n'y a t'il pas à longue échéance un
risque pour le déterminer ce risque pour
le mesurer
on étudie sur des générations d'animaux
les conséquences de l'absorption d'un
produit chimique
nous avons filmé ces images au
laboratoire de l'institut d'hygiène
alimentaire à paris
d'autres centres de recherche
travaillent sur ce même problème du
risque à long terme des additifs
chimiques
mais notre enquête nous a montré que ces
laboratoires ne sont pas assez nombreux
en france
[Musique]
cette étude sur l'animal réclament des
techniques délicate cours desquelles on
observe par exemple l'effet d'un produit
sur le coeur ou sur un autre organe
isolé où l'on surveille en permanence
l'élimination par les urines des
substances étrangères
tout cela est long difficile pour le
fabricant de produits alimentaires c'est
un surcroît de travail une dépense
supplémentaire une perte de temps
sommes nous certains que tous les
industriels de l'alimentation
s'astreignent à une recherche aussi
complète qu'elle devrait l'être avant de
lancer un produit nouveau sur le marché
il est bien difficile de répondre et
d'autant moins que le progrès va très
vite
hier c'était l'arrivée massive des
matières plastiques
demain ça sera la tour à lyon nous avons
rencontré un industriel qui met au point
un procédé révolutionnaire très efficace
il permet par exemple d'empêcher la
germination des pommes de terre ou des
oignons problème essentiel pour
l'économie agricole et aussi pour la
santé des consommateurs car les pommes
de terre germées sont toxiques
[Musique]
ce procédé permet aussi de stériliser
les aliments de telle sorte qu'on peut
ensuite conservées pendant des mois à la
température ordinaire du jambon ou du
poulet
il permet encore de lutter efficacement
contre tous les ennemis des produits
alimentaires en détruisant dans l'écrin
par exemple les insectes ou les microbes
c'est un procédé merveilleux mais il ne
suscite pas un enthousiasme immédiat car
il consiste à irradier les aliments sous
une source radioactive une sorte de
bombe au cobalt
on se demande tout de suite si les
consommateurs de ces aliments irradiés
ne risque pas d'être contaminés nous
avons posé la question et monsieur vidal
le promoteur de cette méthode en france
va vous poser une question qu'on pose
régulièrement parce que les gens
lorsqu'on parle d'irradiation par tous
pense tout de suite aux tombées
radioactives or si vous voulez c'est une
pacification de ses produits radioactifs
et nous pouvons les utiliser très
couramment comme vous utilisé couramment
l'électricité actuellement sans aucun
danger et le produire votre à wiener en
dehors des questions danger le produit
reste et pas deux
dénaturer d'avoir un autre un goût
différent où on y rit si vous utilisez
des très grandes doses vous pouvez avoir
des transformations un produit mais dans
les doses pour les produits je vous
présente ici il ya aucune transformation
et les produits sont excellents et ne
présente aucun danger
est ce qu'il existe des expériences
similaires à l'étranger house est dans
ce domaine les trois pays pionniers ont
été les états unis l'angleterre et la
france et ces pays ont fait beaucoup
d'expériences rituellement la situation
est la suivante le canada autorisé de
irradié des pommes de terre pour les
commercialiser actuellement les
industriels canadiens construisent une
usine qui pourra traiter 7000 tonnes de
pommes de terre par an et ses rizières
grand nombre de produits vous états unis
il est autorisé de irradiés du bacon 1,4
million et demi draps le sait réaliser
complètement c'est à dire on peut le
conserver la température ordinaire
irradiation des pommes de terre est
autorisée la désinsectisation des
céréales aussi est autorisé et en russie
l'autorisation d'y rallier les pommes de
terre est donné maintenant il est
certain que en amérique
de nombreuses autorisation est donnée en
particulier l'armée américaine envisage
de nourrir une grande partie de ses
troupes avec des produits et gagner et
quand pensez-vous qu'en france on
passera aux dents au stade de
l'industrialisation à le problème ne
dépend pas de moi nous avons déposé un
dossier fin 1962 pour autoriser
d'irradier et de commercialiser les
pommes de terre car il fallait un début
après nous avons un certain nombre
d'autres produits nous l'ont demandé
désinsectisation des céréales
destruction des salmonelles enfin
différents autres produits le dossier
est en cours d'instruction au conseil
supérieur d'hygiène je peux pas vous
dire quand on a une décision négative ou
positive face à une dernière question de
revenir sur la question danger qui est
évidemment celle que nous préoccupe le
plus le public
si aucun danger pour les descendances
par exemple est-ce que vous avez des
contrôles
écoutez sur le problème humain je peux
pas m'aventurer dans ce domaine mais
dans le monde il est fait il était fait
d'un grand nombre d'expériences
premièrement sur la toxicité des dents
alimentaire irradiés et deuxièmement sur
leur valeur alimentaire au point de
toxicité et causticité il a été nourri
des quantités très importantes de rades
sourire de porc de singe pour faire pour
voir la toxicité est depuis depuis au
moins sept huit ans il était fait aussi
des études sur une nourriture de
volontaires de ces nourrie par ces
denrées or l'expérience a montré ses
volontés ont été déduits suivi au point
de vue médical dans tous les domaines on
a commencé d'abord leur faire consommer
pendant trois mois des détails est à 10%
d'henri rallier on est allé jusqu'à 100%
et on a montré qu'il n'y avait aucun
danger et tous les expériences faites
sur les animaux montrent également qu'
aucun danger
l'irradiation des aliments se fait à
lyon dans une installation expérimentale
depuis plusieurs années déjà les
aliments ainsi traités par exposition à
une source de cobalt ne conserve aucune
radioactivité
lorsqu on les présente un compteur rien
ne se passe alors qu'une simple montre
au cadran lumineuse faiblement
radioactifs fait grésillés le compteur
d'une montre ce n'est pourtant pas
dangereux car c'est bien au delà que se
trouve le taux de radioactivité
un homme peut supporter huit heures de
suite chaque jour suivant les normes
internationales mangeons nous bientôt
des aliments stériliser grâce à l'atome
c'est probable il faut croire
l'expérience menée avec soin qui prouve
que cela est non seulement efficace mais
dépourvu de risques mais il faut bien
avouer que cette perspective malgré
toutes les assurances des hommes de
laboratoire n'est pas très
enthousiasmante et l'on comprend ce qui
tournant le dos aux progrès et aux lois
de la production économique ne veulent
acheter que des aliments qu on leur
garantit naturel
[Musique]
les au fait qu'est-ce qu'un aliment
naturel
peut-on réellement dire actuellement que
ça existe l'aliment naturel monsieur
brun pour sa part n'y crois pas je sais
que je vais très méchant vis-à-vis des
gens qui croient l'aliment naturel
personnellement je n'y crois pas ou tout
au moins je n'y crois plus et je crois
que l'aliment naturel n'a jamais existé
au sens strict du terme
le vin le pain sont des produits de
l'industrialisation d'hommes il faut
tout de même presser le raisin le
décanter décanter le jus de raisin
bref lui faire subir un certain nombre
de manipulations
en un mot l'industrialiser pour le
donner au public
donc on peut pas dire au sens strict du
terme que le vin est un aliment naturel
la même façon le fin fond broyer les
grains dans le temps broyer les grains
sur des mâles et dans le temps
j'exagère peut-être un peu mais bien
souvent le meunier d'autrefois boucher
les trous tsemel car ils se produisaient
des trous du fait que bien souvent en
broyant le grain on avait des pierres
qui habille les lamelles ont bouché le
trou des mails avec du plomb est passé
du plomb dans la farine si bien qu'on a
eu des accidents comme ça de saturnisme
avec des farines chargés en plomb par
les mâles qui était boucher avec du plan
ce que je vous dis là est un peu
caricatural mail aliments naturels
n'existe pas et beaucoup de gens
actuellement parle d'aliments naturels
je crois c'est une erreur
merci pour votre franchise monsieur brun
mais où en sommes nous de notre problème
nous les consommateurs
il serait imprudent de notre part de
faire uniquement confiance aux
industriels de l'alimentation
heureusement il existe une garantie une
protection c'est la législation sur les
additifs alimentaires de services de la
répression des fraudes qui dépend du
ministère de l'agriculture est chargé de
faire appliquer cette hésitation
ici dans les laboratoires du service des
fraudes des chimistes analyses des
échantillons prélevés chez les
fabricants ou les commerçants il en
arrive cent mille par an des opérations
que vous suivez sont quelques étapes de
l'analyse d'une huile d'arachide
suspecte le service des fraudes a la
lourde tâche de faire respecter une loi
stricte et qui ne tolère aucune
exception
il n'est autorisé en france qu'un nombre
limité d'additifs chimiques dans les
aliments
ce sont ceux dont l'absence de nocivité
est garantie par les travaux des
meilleurs experts tout ce qui n'est pas
autorisé est automatiquement interdit
l'usagé en est considéré comme une
fraude sévèrement réprimée
mais pouvons-nous être certains que les
fraudes sont toujours dépisté à temps
comme nous le rappelle monsieur spiteri
son directeur lorsque leur abattoir fut
créée en 1907 les problèmes n'étaient
pas aussi scientifique aujourd'hui les
fraudes les plus courantes étaient par
exemple le mouillage des vins ou du lait
ou encore l'addition au café de pois
chiches torréfié ce n'est plus du tout
la même chose aujourd'hui
n'est ce pas monsieur spiteri c'était
l'époque de la fronde à la papa depuis
les choses ont beaucoup changé
nous avons une évolution considérable
pas dans le concept de la défense des
végétaux ou l'utilisation de dérivés
chlorés multiples l'utilisation des
stars de l'acide phosphorique la
production agricole enfin les façons le
volant les substances alimentaires font
l'objet de conservation de présentation
de plus en plus appétissantes et pour la
conservation pour la présentation il a
été proposé des quantités considérables
de substances des antibiotiques des
instrus oxygène des colorants des les
gélifiants enfin je vous fais grâce de
toutes ces substances dans certaines
sont à dix et additionner en quantité
extrêmement faible mais je comprends
mais est-ce que vis-à-vis de cette
pression sans cesse plus grande des
industriels et des et des chimistes
est ce que vous possédez toutes les
armes pour résister à cette pression
écoutez je vous dirais n'est ce pas que
le tout le service de la répression des
fraudes du comprendre quand même près de
350 personnes disséminées sur toute la
france et qui comprend quand même des
laboratoires important est bien le
couteau budget zéro franc 25 par un
français il était il est incontestable
que si on augmente et cette somme on
pouvait nous permettre d'être peut-être
plus rapide dans l'examen des
les demandes d'autorisation aussi bien
rapide pour l'acceptation que pour le
rejet alors là il damas une certaine
lenteur qui est inhérente à la modicité
il est déjà prévu d'agrandir et de
moderniser le laboratoire du service des
fraudes qui est actuellement à l'étroit
et surcharger son rôle essentiel est de
faire respecter la loi
mais ce sont des experts des
toxicologues par exemple qui au départ
ont la responsabilité de décider si un
produit chimique doit non être incorporé
à notre alimentation nous sommes allés à
la faculté de pharmacie pour interroger
l'un de ces experts le professeur
trudeau son assistant monsieur joannie
nous montre comment sur un lapin on juge
d'abord de la toxicité immédiate d'un
produit nouveau donc ce lapin est
installé avec une aiguille dans une
veine pour lui permettre de faire
l'injection intraveineuse un appareil à
ventilation artificielle et sous la main
en cas qu'une défaillance dilatoire
surviennent ce qui serait déjà un
premier enseignement mais qui nous
arrêtera immédiatement l'expérience si
la ventilation des farines animales et
ventilés par l'appareil et on peut
continuer à voir les variations soient
cardiovasculaires soi et les
transphotographiques qui pourrait
intervenir alors je vais lui passait
actuellement une certaine quantité d'un
produit qui n'est en principe pas
dangereux l'injection est fait en même
temps je mets en route
l'enregistrement électrocardiographique
électroencéphalographique et on peut
surveiller par exemple les modifications
de la pression artérielle une légère
hypotension est en train de s'installer
le long voir si elle sera récupérée vous
les modifications cardiovasculaires vous
pouvez quand même déjà les remarques et
j'en ai fait que vous voyez surtout sur
la piste du bas donc a priori se prenant
qu'à priori samedi serait méchant c'est
une surprise
il faut se garer des surprises c'est
pour ça c'est tout à fait l'intérêt de
ce genre de l'épreuve
[Musique]
si le produit a passé ce premier cap
s'il n'a pas montré de toxicité au cours
d'expériences répétés sur divers animaux
on entreprend alors que d'une autre
série de recherches pour juger de son
danger à long terme est bien entendu
surtout de l'activité qu'il pourrait
présenter dans le domaine du cancer
comme nous l'expliquent le professeur
trudeau la première démonstration effet
cancérogène d'une matière colorante au
moins chez l'animal a été fait sur un
produit qu'on appelle jaune de beurre
qui se rattachent à la série des
azoïques et bien dans certains pays ils
étaient utilisés et ceci justifierait
dans une certaine mesure la crainte qu
on est d'exprimer
mais en france on ne l'avait pas
employer car déjà les hygiénistes en
considérant sa formule et certains
effets sur la cellule considéré que
c'était un produit dangereux mais on a
vu sur le plan des médicaments
thérapeutiques des problèmes comme celui
par exemple de la thalidomide est ce que
ça ne risque pas de se produire aussi en
ce qui concerne les additifs chimiques
dans l'alimentation
si l'on effectue les expérimentations
selon les critères qui ont été définies
dans des protocoles qui ont même été
publiés en france au journal officiel
et bien ce risque est exclue puisque il
est recommandé d'effectuer des essais
sur des animaux gravides et d'un taché
est la plus grande attention à observer
les petits leur vitalité leurs
éventuelles malformations
et d'autres phénomènes la nativité c'est
à dire que avant d'autoriser un produit
vous faites donc une expérimentation sur
l'animal qui s'étagent sur plusieurs
générations de limonest fin absolument
et qui sait tâche est qui et qui est
effectuée également sur plusieurs
espèces animales et cette
expérimentation est très délicate car
elle concerne toute une série d'aspects
aspect pharmacodynamique aspect
biochimiques détermination des
modifications sanguine altération
histologique considération des fonctions
de reproduction de la vitalité des
petits comme je viens de lire tout à
l'heure et considérations également des
effets cancérogènes éventuel c'est à
dire de la production que tu meurs
donc on peut dire que le toxicologue
pour l'instant est une barrière efficace
contre le danger possible résultant de
l'introduction de produits chimiques
dangereux dans l'alimentation
c'est à dire qu'il faudrait donc face à
la poussée de la chimie augmenté
l'armement d'armement préventif aux
quelque sorte
si vous me permettez de
faire une comparaison au siècle dernier
lorsque notre ce citoyen du monde que
fut pasteur a découvert le danger des
bactéries et bien dans le domaine
alimentaire spécifiquement on a accordé
une très grande importance au contrôle
microbiologique des aliments et on a
fondé toute une série de laboratoire
pour effectuer ce contrôle
eh bien il faudrait qu'il en soit de
même dans le cas du contrôle des agents
chimiques ajoutés aux animaux parce que
leurs dangers pour être plus insidieux
moins spectaculaire si vous voulez n'en
sont à mon avis certainement pas moyen
pour assurer une protection plus
efficace du consommateur il faudrait
donc un armement meyer davantage de
laboratoire
ce jeune homme qui paraît se promener va
nous conduire vers un autre système de
protection contre le danger chimot
suivant lit
[Musique]
dix ans tout maîtriser l'orangerie voilà
un peu partout dans paris ce jeune homme
a acheté des sucettes et des bonbons ils
les portent à gennevilliers où se trouve
le laboratoire coopératif d'analysé et
de recherche fondé par des consommateurs
ce laboratoire effectue systématiquement
des prélèvements sur divers aliments
dans les magasins aujourd'hui il s'agit
de sucettes
hier c'était du fromage demain ce sera
la viande
une équipe de chimistes travaillent
ainsi en dehors de toute pression des
fabricants sans être relié à aucun
organisme officiel pour vérifier si nos
aliments ne contiennent pas de
substances nocives les sucettes par
exemple sont fondus pour en extraire sur
de la laine les colorants qui sont
ensuite triés par la technique de la
chromatographie
[Musique]
cette technique consiste à un bib et un
papier buvard d'un mélange des divers
colorants chacun d'eux s'étale de façon
particulière ce qui permet à la fois de
les séparer et de les identifier
[Musique]
de même que pour tous les autres
produits chimiques
on ne peut utiliser dans les aliments
que des colorants figurant sur la liste
officielle
la fraude est donc facile à mettre en
lumière
c'est ce qui s'est produit à
gennevilliers où l'analyse des
échantillons de sucettes a mises en
évidence dans plusieurs cas la présence
de colorants interdits
lorsque les chimistes du laboratoire
coopératif découvre une telle fraude ils
publient leurs conclusions de façon
aussi large qu'ils le peuvent
il ne dispose d'aucun pouvoir pour agir
sur les fraudeurs mais déjà le seul fait
que leurs laboratoires existait un frein
efficace contre l'intrusion croissante
de produits chimiques dans notre
alimentation comme va nous le dire
monsieur custeau le directeur du
laboratoire
cela est particulièrement important
lorsqu'il s'agit de la santé des enfants
[Musique]
vous venez de faire dans ce laboratoire
l'analyste quelques dizaines de sucettes
et de bombo quels ont été les résultats
de ce travail
eh bien nous avons sur 226 échantillon
de bonbons et de sucettes trouvait au
total 416 colorants de différentes
espèces et sur ses 416 colorants 7
n'appartenait pas la liste des colorants
autorisés donc était au regard de la
législation française des colorants
interdits
c'est ça c'était l'objet de votre
travail c'est à dire de voir si les
fabriques horde sucettes et de brobo
suivait uno la législation en vigueur
c'est ça un contrôle de la part des
consommateurs si vous voulez pour voir
de quelle manière
sur un échantillon évidemment faible en
fait de quelle manière les consommateurs
sont protégés dans ce domaine vous ne
représentez donc aucun organisme
officiel vous êtes le représentant de
tous les consommateurs en quelque sorte
notre laboratoire est en france le seul
qui travaille pour le compte exclusif
des associations consommateurs et qui se
préoccupe en leur nom de savoir si le
degré de protection qui l'aurait assuré
et suffisants c'est ça alors quels sont
les grands problèmes que vous cherchez à
il eut cité est bien l'un de ses grands
problèmes est incontestablement celui
des répercussions du progrès technique
sur notre alimentation moderne car on
pourrait faire de longs développements
mais enfin il est bien connu que les
circonstances de notre économie moderne
amène notamment à multiplier les
procédés techniques les substances
chimiques qui viennent interférer avec
ce qu'on appelait autrefois
l'alimentation traditionnelle et les
colorants constitue un exemple de cela
les colorants sont particulièrement
graves pourquoi les colorants ne sont
pas particulièrement grave
on peut dire que parmi les substances
d'ajouter ce sont d'abord les plus
visibles
et pour cause et que en second lieu
elles ont fait l'objet je crois des
travaux les plus poussées notamment du
point de vue des problèmes de
cancérisation et on peut dire que d'une
façon générale c'est très
vraisemblablement le secteur où le
consommateur français et même le
consommateur de tous les pays et le
mieux protégé mais nous avons tout de
même voulu nous en assurer d'une part et
d'autre part porter attention aux
bonbons et aux sucettes c'est-à-dire à
quelque chose qui était destiné tout de
même à aux enfants par conséquent à une
catégorie particulièrement intéressante
est digne d'intérêt de la population en
ce qui concerne l'ensemble de la
question l'ensemble des additifs
chimiques dans l'alimentation est ce que
la france a une situation particulière
bonne ou mauvaise par rapport aux pays
étrangers
écoutez c'est là une question sûrement
très controversé il est d'usagé nous
avons nous sommes amusés à faire une
petite collection de ce que l'on dit
dans les différents pays de la
législation de ce pays considéré et bien
c'est la phrase est toujours la même
dans notre pays où la protection du
consommateur est meilleur que partout
ailleurs etc etc
la france n'échappe pas à cette règle
c'est à dire que les affirmations ils
sont souvent optimistes
à notre avis la réalité est un peu moins
brillante sans qu'on puisse dire qu'elle
soit catastrophique mais enfin la france
qui était en 1950 au début de ce siècle
incontestablement à l'avant garde en ce
domaine a perdu un certain nombre de
positions au profit de pays qui ont soit
une législation plus stricte comme ça
semble être le cas de la récente
législation allemande soit surtout
peut-être un contrôle infiniment mieux
assurer comme c'est le cas par exemple
de la suisse où je me permets de le
rappeler les résultats des laboratoires
officiels vont
ou mauvais sont régulièrement publiés
dans des journaux dont le public peut
prendre connaissance ce que nous n'avons
cessé de demander pour la france vous
pensez donc il faut encore faire un
effort et qu'il faut rendre la
réglementation encore plus strictes elle
ne l'est à l'heure actuelle joue le jeu
le crois et je crois surtout qu'il faut
donner aux services de contrôle dont
l'activité est extrêmement méritoires
des moyens matériels infiniment plus
importants que ceux dont il dispose
actuellement
mais est ce qu'on peut dire que les
fabricants produits alimentaires ont
tout de même une conscience de ces
problèmes et qu'il faut en général ce
qu'il faut pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
problème sanitaire ou d'hygiène
je crois que cette question a deux
aspects sur le plan moral
il est certain que ils ont conscience de
leurs devoirs
sur le plan technique je dirais c'est
plus inégal car certains fabricants
peuvent avoir de très bonnes intentions
mais ne pas disposer des moyens
techniques de les mener à exécution et
notamment je crois que s'il y avait un
peu plus de laboratoires bien outillés
dans l'industrie alimentaire française
ce serait certainement un pas en avant
mais je crois aussi que il n'y a pas
qu'une question ni d'intention ni même
de thé forts concrets de la part des
industriels
il y a aussi cette pente naturelle qui
amène l'industrie alimentaire à aller de
plus en plus vers les produits chimiques
ajoutés les traitements nouveaux
insuffisamment connue et que dans ce
domaine là incontestablement il ya
besoin d'un contrepoids que
l'organisation des consommateurs se
préoccupent de réaliser voilà notre
enquête est terminée elle aura
probablement rassuré les uns et inquiété
les autres mais il faut aussi justifier
notre titre faudra-t-il en l'an 2000
nous habituer à faire ce que font déjà
les cosmonautes sucer dans une capsule
de plastique un aliment concentré
artificielle sorti tout droit d'une
usine ou d'un laboratoire
[Musique]
non il ne semble pas
pas plus que nous ne serons obligés
comme certains l'ont avancé un peu vite
de manger des chlorelle ces algues qui
poussent très rapidement dans de grands
bacs et dont on sait déjà faire de la
poudre dont la valeur nutritive équivaut
à celle de la viande
[Musique]
en l'an 2000 que mangeons-nous alors les
repas en pilules pour mon cas personnel
je resterai au vif tac frites
je tiens à vous le dire est ce que le
bifteck frites l'an 2000 alors ne sera
pas disons plus chimique que celui
d'aujourd'hui non je ne pense pas droit
de l'hommiste écrits de l'an 2000 sera
un bifteck et des frites qui ont
augmenté en qualité et ça me permet
ainsi de vous parler de la qualité des
aliments
beaucoup de gens parlent sans trop
savoir ce qu'ils disent
la qualité en valeur absolue n'existe
quoi la qualité est une chose relative
c'est relatif par rapport aux
découvertes de la biochimie et des
besoins de notre organisme plus on va
améliorer une substance alimentaires en
fonction de nos connaissances la
biochimie plus à ce moment là on pourra
parler de qualité est certain qu'en l'an
2000 le bifteck frites sera un bifteck
fait à partir de bêtes qui ont reçu
l'alimentation tels le lift extra puis
temps de bifteck apportera des acides
aminés indispensables en quantité des
plus grands les frites seront faits à
partir de pommes de terre sélectionnés
dont les constituants glucidique ont été
améliorés peut-être c'est une idée comme
une autre peut-être des vitamines en
meilleur en plus grande quantité qui
viennent dans l'ensemble vive tech
frites aura une qualité biologique
augmenté huile servant à la confection
des frites rapt était une huile
compte tenu de l'éducation du
consommateur et de l'aménager pour être
qu une fois et on aura peut-être trouvé
des traces d'arachide ou des races de
colza tels que cette huile au cours de
la cuisson s'altère - voilà dans quel
sens je vois l'évolution l'alimentation
vers d'autres optimiste oui je suis
optimiste
réseauter
[Musique]